Little Big Town revealed how Justin
Timberlake played a part in their new
album wanderlust while on the red carpet
of these CMT Awards on Wednesday it was
fantastic
you guys are all on Instagram and we
love following you guys we've seen we
know Pharrell is working with Justin and
we know you guys have worked with Justin
what is going on I see I'm connecting
dots here we were in the studio at the
same time so we have Justin in one room
and we had Little Big Town in another
room and you know quite naturally people
are gonna come you know people are gonna
visit each other and it was just like
this really natural thing and Justin
ended up singing on one of em one of the
songs on his he sang backgrounds and on
come on it was like the old days when
artists used to hang out at the studio
and he came down and listened to what we
were doing he's like oh my gosh what if
I sang this you know it's like it was
very fun and he's a Tennessee boy and we
had that connection all of us it was a
southern southern fun party yeah it's
all it's the South getting together